So to get a better feel for this last way to fill out the chart,
I'm going to walk through a bit of a parse to show you how it goes.
I've got the grammar here in the upper right and here's my input string,
and I'm going to abuse notation a bit,
by using this red dot again to mean: Where We Are.
So, conceptually, one of the first things we'll do is shift.
We saw the integer token,
and we were expecting that because one of our parse states here was:
(E --> red dot int) from zero.
But now we want to turn this (int) into an (E)
by using this rule, in reverse.
And that's a bit magical for now, but we'll see why we want to do it, real shortly.
Then we'll want to shift over the (+).
It fits with our grammar and it's the input token we saw,
and next, we'll want to shift over this (int).
And now we'll want to replace this (int) with an (E),
just like we did above.
So this was another instance of magic
or this third new rule that we're going to be talking about.
And then, finally, now we've got an (E + E)
and if we look up here in our grammar,
(E) can be rewritten as (E + E).
So we use magic once again, and the process will continue.
Each of these times, when we've taken
a token or a terminal in the input
and replaced it with a nonterminal,
has been an instance of reduction.
And if we were to view this in the opposite order,
we'd see it as a parse tree.
At the end of the day, I'm going to ally it a lot of details.
We'd end up with this; and the shrinking input,
as I replace these terminals or tokens with nonterminals,
sort of corresponds to how my tree
edges in here--same sort of pattern.
I have more and more Whitespace on the left,
more and more Whitespace on the left.
So the relationship between this magic step
and parsing should be pretty clear,
but I still need to tell you how to do it--
how do we actually perform reductions.